hallo leute ich es wieder einmal wand
und willkommen zu einem neuen video
ich wollte wie schmeckt sagen und
eigentlich ist es ja auch ein geschmeckt
weil ich heute versuchen möchte meine
lieblings barbie aus meinem lieblings
bubble tea laden nachzumachen einige von
euch haben vielleicht schon das letzte
video gesehen in dem ich habe es
getestet habe und auch wenn alle anderen
barbies super lecker sind wollte ich
heute zwei nachmachen einmal meine
northeim favorite perlen milch und
natürlich habe ich mich auch gut
vorbereitet denn für einen perlen milch
braucht man tab york ap ich kann euch
bis heute nicht sagen was tapioka perlen
sind die zutaten sind tabu gaston giani
kokott congstar c400 12 262
es ist ein produkt auf china und auch
wenn ich ihn liebe weiß ich nicht genau
wie sie damit lebensmittel verordnungen
sind in good old germany oder europa
muss man ja einige voraussetzungen
erfüllen dass ein lebensmittel verkauft
werden da und da gibt es dann zum
beispiel inhaltsstoffe oder dinge die
nicht ein produkt drin sein dürfen ich
weiß jetzt nicht ich hab's gekauft darf
also ist es ja es hat auch china und
tapioka perlen sind halt irgendwie
wiegen gummibärchen weich aber auch
irgendwie fest und irgendwie supergeil
der geschmack ist unbeschreiblich
wenn ihr mal die chance hat einen perlen
mächtige auszuprobieren macht es ich sag
mal so 50 50 werden es mögen oder nicht
so kompliziert kann es nicht sein weil
da steht ready in fünf minute sie sehen
aber ehrlich gesagt auch super ort aus
wie so kleine steine sie sind auch super
hart das wort schiff wird kommen wir
aber zu unserer steigen zutat
es ist so war glaube in köln sind heute
irgendwie 40 grad bei uns nur 35 aber da
bekommen wir doch immer richtig lust auf
schwarzem tee das ist die zweite
hauptzutat für einen perlen mit
schwarztee und ich hab hier vom twinings
prince of wales die genommen ich bin mir
sicher dass sie bei com bei darjeeling
benutzen ich muss aber sagen als ich
diesen tee gerochen habe er riecht
wirklich original wie der perle nicht
schmeckt also dachte ich muss ja dann
besser sollen das sollte eigentlich
schon klappen ich habe nur ein bisschen
sorgen weil sie beim laden so eine
espressomaschine haben wo sie hat er
reinmachen kennt ihr diese barista
maschinen wo man das so und dann so und
damit druck wird das so rausgeschossen
ja und warum ich dachte dass der auch
gut passt da steht nämlich speed
objektiv und was braucht man als dritte
zutat für einen perlen milch natürlich
milch laktosefrei ohne durchfall dann
werden eiswürfel natürlich nicht
schlecht und wir brauchen etwas um die
ganze geschichte zu süßen da würde ich
braunen t sogar vorschlagen
denn der hat so einen leicht karamell im
geschmack vielleicht bilde ich mir das
auch nur ein und er schmeckt ganz normal
aber ja was zutaten zucker und karamell
deswegen schmeckt das so caramelle ich
auch gute geschmacksnerven und das sind
alle zutaten die man braucht und als
kleines extra habe ich natürlich noch
was gesorgt
ein echter brecher wie im babylon und ja
es ist plastik bitte bringt mich um ich
wollte unbedingt fürs video haben
[Musik]
jetzt machen wir unseren bubble tea okay
ich wollte eigentlich hier so old school
wie schmeckt perspektive machen aber wir
müssen dafür die kamera drehen
das ist zu viel wir sehen uns jetzt
gleich wieder willkommen in meinem
bubble tea laden was kann ich dir dann
bringt ein pft kommt sofort ich habe
beim letzten mal die mitarbeiter aufs
genaueste beobachtet was sie tun und
sind ja meistens zwei und die machen
alles irgendwie gleichzeitig das weg
habe ich keine reihenfolge die man jetzt
befolgen sollen aber das ist kein
problem wir machen es einfach frei
schnauze wie wir glauben dass es am
besten zuerst kochen wir wasser für
unseren schwarztee
[Musik]
ist euch eigentlich schon ein gutes kind
aufgefallen ich schaue ja schon lange
die ganze nation serien auf netflix auch
wirklich und mein neuester goldstück hat
mit all ihren vor in vail internet love
ich bin bei folge zwei junge die
asiatischen männer sind echte romantisch
hatte jemanden wir sind schwarz die rein
wir machen mal so 123 teelöffel und
führen da schon was drauf weniger ja
lecker schwarz die super cool aus den
lassen wir jetzt ein bisschen ziehen und
ein derzeit kümmern wir uns um die
tapioka perlen wollten cups auf worte
habs ja wir haben kraft wir brauchen ten
cars of water auf kochendes wasser in
den radsport das passiert wenn man den
satz nicht seine liebste ich hab kein
radsport ach so ich habe tatsächlich
noch da die linke gefunden der
anscheinend in dem metier original drin
sein sollte und falls mein anderer
schwarztee nicht wirklich funktioniert
haben wir das noch als backup aber man
muss auch bei schwarztee aufpassen oder
der wird auch ganz schnell bitter drückt
das hier nur hunde the water ist cooking
now we can stand jetzt kommt ein
kaputter verein langsam ins wasser geben
und dabei umrühren
so und jetzt warten wir darauf dass die
perlen nach oben steigen das ist super
spannend meine damen und herren ich
filme an der zeit ist dass hier ab so
die tapioka ferien sind jetzt alle oben
und jetzt decke zu und mittlere hitze
alexa stellen time auf zwei minuten
[Musik]
alexa erzählen wird
hier kauft ihr könnt ihr mal sehen
das sind unsere tapioka perlen und hier
haben wir einmal sind die link fsd.de
und den scheinen wie groß die werden
braucht keine das wasser muss schon mal
vorbereiten
jetzt haben wir die hitze aufgemacht und
lassen sie noch für weitere zwei minuten
zu humpeln
alexa umtriebigkeit zu machen
immerhin vorstellen
jetzt können wir das ding smudo 20
sekunden ein
[Musik]
sondern in q3 bolt ich bin so stolz
also ich habe nichts getan wirklich weh
tun sie nix sie klingen so richtig eklig
letztmaligen ganz bisschen honig rein
jetzt eines hannibals fachhandel papier
gab er ein team muss unbedingt eine
probieren sie sind perfekt geworden dies
haben wir unsere stadt joh kapellen wir
haben unseren schwarztee der schmecken
besser
wir nehmen hier und jetzt wo wir alle
unsere zutaten zusammen haben muss es in
neben mixa ich weiß jetzt leider nicht
wie viel von was überhaupt rein soll
aber das ist bestimmt das machen wir so
ein bisschen nach gefühl
auf jeden fall dass man guten schuss
milch ist ein wichtiger
wir müssten auch in seinem braunen
zucker wir machen doch braun zu den
themen aber jetzt kommt unseren
wir machen einfach was von dem denken
ja er hat nicht ganz die farbe vom
original
wir haben einfach noch mal rein so jetzt
kommen wir noch als würfel und schrauben
das zu und nun kommen wir zur
zusammenstellung zuerst nehmen wir
unsere taktik ab
da haben wir natürlich jetzt alle rein
das passt auch von der größe da brauchen
wir noch ein bisschen eis und jetzt muss
unser rhein gekippt werden
[Musik]
und hier ist er unser allererster planen
möchte ich mein so schlecht oder gar
nicht aus oder für unseren ersten und
nun stellen wir uns wieder der
allerwichtigsten frage wie schmeckt der
perlen milch tee aus und auch ganz
vielen anderen legen die ich jetzt
leider nicht kenne und deswegen ganz nah
kam bei sage profil als allererstes er
schmeckt mega gut nur eine sache fällt
mir auf der iss halt überhaupt nicht so
süß wie das original haben wir hier etwa
an den zucker skandal aufgedeckt ja
diese übertriebene süße fehlt ich mache
meinen eigentlich schon immer mit
weniger süß aber ich glaube dass weniger
süß immer noch richtig süß eigentlich
ist ganz ehrlich das ist wahrscheinlich
einfach die ds version von dem wirst du
nicht so das ist
kelis doch auf diät kelly guck mal ich
hab für dich extra einen perlen mächtig
gemacht den du auch während einer diät
reden kannst hammer ich meine dass er
jetzt 350 gekostet und eure kriege
würden nicht aussehen als ob eine bombe
explodiert wäre aber songs ich meinen
sohn bubble tea party zuhause
veranstalten
mit selber per machen jetzt auch voll
cool film kindergeburtstag ja klar denkt
dran leuchte daran kann man sie
verschlucken wirklich gibt es nicht
euren kleinen geschwister ich hab
natürlich hat das video gefallen und das
ergebnis wenn ihr das auch schon mal
nach gemacht habt oder jetzt auch nach
machen wollt schaut es mir gerne in die
kommentare und schreibt mir auch gerne
was ihr für videos noch gerne sehen
wollt schreibt mir wie warm es bei euch
ist vielleicht ist die hitzewelle schon
wieder weg wenn ihr das video seht und
für noch mehr geht ihr aber auf michaels
kanal für unstable stylus grades homo
werbung hier
du bist bescheid klage ich kenne ihn
hier zu schlagen
es ist sowas wie sich das bald wieder
all of china